this is a 50 caliber round for a
Barrett's anti-material rifle while this
is a 50 caliber round for a desert eagle
both a 50 caliber and both are fired
from weapons that many of you have used
in dozens of video games but obviously
they're also very different
so what does caliber mean what can it
tell us about the virtual Firearms we're
carrying into multiplayer matches and
when it comes to video games does it
even matter we've come here to the Royal
armories in Leeds to learn a little more
about calibers and cartridges and to
find out how much impact this seemingly
small detail has in today's biggest
games
foreign
caliber is a term we've read and heard
countless times as we've tinkered with
our FPS loadouts or storm through story
missions but what does it mean and what
can it tell us about our favorite
virtual Weaponry while many are familiar
with the word caliber being used as a
descriptor for whatever pixelated
firearm we're using in a game the term
is technically referring to the interior
diameter of the barrel or bore of a gun
today it is also a term frequently used
in respect of the weapons ammunition as
the measurements for both the barrel and
the bullet fired would of course be very
close so for example Agent 47 Silver
Ballers have an internal barrel diameter
of roughly 0.45 inches chambered for the
45 ACP cartridge type and would be
described as being a 45 caliber pistol
shotgun gauges are related but a little
weirder the gauge refers to how many
balls you could make from one pound of
lead if each ball was the same diameter
as the barrel so 12 gauge 12 balls of 1
12 of a pound each and a 0.729 inch
barrel 20 gauge 20 smaller balls so
smaller cartridge and smaller Barrel
another term that is similar yet still
distinct is cartridge a cartridge or
round is the entire package that makes
up the ammunition in most cases today
being the bullet the case propellant rim
and primer however the nomenclature of
ammunition and their descriptors can
cause some confusion especially when
jumping between measurements of calibers
metric measurements and cartridge types
the cartridge type is literally the type
of cartridge that given firearm is
designed to fire so if I could go back
in time and reinvent the English
language one of the things I would do is
stop calling types of cartridge caliber
because it gets really confusing caliber
strictly speaking is just that internal
diameter or the diameter of the
projectile even I will call say 5.56 by
45 millimeters the NATO standard rifle
round
a caliber because that's just how the
language has evolved but for clarity I
use the term cartridge type so 5.56 is
the caliber 5.56 by 45 or 5.56
millimeter Nato is a cartridge type
that's the difference
however it's important to keep in mind
that within collections of calibers not
all booms are created equal while two
weapons May technically be the same
caliber they can have varying ballistics
applications measurements power or be
different guns altogether let's take two
of the most iconic weapons in pop
culture the Desert Eagle 50 caliber
pistol and the 50 caliber Barrett
anti-material rifle these are both big
imposing weapons that we've seen
countless times in our games each
commonly portrayed firing a 50 caliber
round but because of a very different
cartridge type as well as different
propellant measurements and of course
the weapon system the 50 cal rounds that
each fire are very distinct despite
sharing a name
when we say 50 caliber we we're probably
thinking of 50 BMG 50 Browning machine
gun so half an inch diameter bullet of a
set overall cut overall bullet length of
a particular design in a super long
bottlenecked case with a load of
capacity for propellant to burn 50
caliber for the Desert Eagle is
something very different indeed it's the
same diameter bullet but good luck
fitting a 50 BMG round into a desert
eagle and even if your 50 action Express
which is the cartridge type round might
somehow cram into a Barrett it's not
going to do very much it's a much much
shorter cartridge case as well so
although it's very powerful by Pistol
standards it's just not a very practical
proposition for most things
foreign
but what does this mean for our games
how much relation is there between
virtual calibers and the real ones
whilst somewhat aware of the differences
games are able to tap into the general
awareness players have of different
cartridges and calibers in a surprising
number of ways especially when you
consider that for your average shooter
it is a fairly minor detail
while many games obviously have
different damage profiles for various
weapons in their virtual armories they
generally follow established tropes or
similar real world differences between
the calibers and their connected
Firearms so for the vast majority of
Shooters whenever an AK-47 or akm type
weapon is featured it assumes to be
firing the larger 7.62 by 39 millimeter
round so we'll do more damage than the
virtual M16 firing the smaller 5.56 by
45 millimeter round generally and with
all other things being equal the reality
of the ak's larger heavier 7.16
millimeter bullet means that more energy
is transferred to the Target and more
recoil is felt in the shooter
while the M16 5.56 millimeter round is
smaller lighter flies with a flatter
trajectory and with less recoil being
felt
while I am certainly no expert on the
science of calibers and that is a rather
Broad and sweeping statement on the
subject it's nonetheless interesting
that virtual rifles will follow the same
established data and Trends but some
games have to stretch some real world
differences to create different gameplay
experiences or Gunplay even within the
same caliber of weapon in reality
factors such as barrel length and
rifling all have some effect on the
ballistics of a fire bullet but four
standard issue military rifles with the
same length barrel firing the same 5.56
by 45 millimeter round could be expected
to perform somewhat similarly and output
similar damage however in many games the
need to create variety between a slew of
weapons available to the player means
that many Firearms firing the same
caliber can vary in their stats
performance and damage to a much higher
degree than they may be expected to in
the real world
although even within those examples it's
still when there is a change in caliber
where Gamers can expect to see the
largest swings and stats or fewer shots
to kill I believe much of the reason why
many modern Shooters have started to
showcase the caliber of the weapon As a
detail in the descriptions or
customization options is because to the
mainstream gamer they'll take these
bigger numbers to Simply mean a bigger
bullet and that bigger is better but is
that always the case now back in the
days of muzzle loaders yes a larger
bullet meant more destruction in
strictly literal terms with with
handguns the same applies so the bigger
diameter bullet the slightly bigger the
hole in the Target but what's much more
important is the velocity certainly for
right for rifles machine guns it's the
speed the thing is traveling in terms of
handguns the bigger the better but then
you have the massive trade-off problem
of fewer rounds in the gun and more
recoil to have to try to get on target
so that's a trade-off situation that's
also true of rifles you know not
everyone carries a 50 Barrett around
with them for for a reason but if you
are able to to then yes the bigger
heavier bullet is nearly always more
destructive mass times velocity is the
critical thing to think about the class
of weapon in video games can also
influence or be influenced by player
expectations so regardless of the
caliber of the bolt action sniper rifle
you're firing the average player is
going to expect their target to go down
with a single hit to the head or chest
this can become even more confusing when
games take a similar sniper rifle firing
the same caliber round except one is a
bolt action and the other is
semi-automatic with the latter taking a
pretty substantial hit to its damage
profile
or in the case of Battlefield 4 the
Scout Elite bolt action rifle fires the
same 5.56 by 45 millimeter Nato round as
many of the game's assault rifles but of
course with vastly different damage and
statistics and in the former having the
capability of a One-Shot kill
well of course they're different weapons
altogether with a scout even having a
barrel around two inches longer than the
game's M16 so of course there would be
some differences in reality but this
serves as another example how games have
to take real deviations and extrapolate
them in order for a weapon to fit into a
niche or a class now this disparity is
most obvious in more mainstream Shooters
like Call of Duty or Battlefield because
today just about any gun has the
capacity to mortally wound in one shot
but that type of gameplay isn't what
people play these types of shooters for
and yet I'm sure there are people out
there who have noticed similar
disparities between a caliber and the
Damage Done to an enemy player and have
been frustrated and Confused how your
opponent could walk off a hit and let's
check the question how did they not die
from that at your television or maybe
that's just me
we have to remember however for most
games adherence to a weapons caliber
isn't nearly as important as having
Variety in weapons and gameplay that
allows for intense firefights that
aren't overly punishing but on the other
end of the spectrum we have games like
escape from tarkov squad or hell that
loose where pretty much any weapon
firing any ammunition hitting the right
spot has the capacity to kill with a
single shot
I'm not sure that the what we call the
terminal effect or The Terminal
ballistics or the wound ballistics of
different calibers is particularly well
carried across to popular culture you
know you'll see 12 gauge shotguns
flinging someone across the room they're
inconsistent at the very least I think
the biggest feature for me of calibers
in movies or anything else is the name
recognition you know the Colt 45 or 44
magnum whether they're realistically
depicted is is Hit or Miss but you know
if the caliber is included in the name
it's because it's part of the name if
that makes sense well this is the 44
Magnum Auto mag
we've come a long way from when games
would simply tell a player that they
picked up generic pistol or rifle ammo
and those rounds were fit for purpose in
just about any weapon of their class
today we can't underestimate the
recognition and familiarity many players
have with certain firearms and the pull
that recognition can have on players
many weapons in reality have included a
nod to their caliber in their name
Jonathan earlier mentioned examples such
as the Colt 45 or 44 magnum calibers
that inspired the image of a 1911 pistol
or revolver in the mind of the player
there are also weapons like the ump45
the spaz 12 or the as50 that include
references to the round they fire
which in turn increases player
familiarity with their calibers whenever
they're incorporated into digital
arsenals even fictional weapons such as
the Apex Legends 3030 repeater
references the popular real-world 3030
caliber commonly used in lever action
rifles and even real world weapons
showcased under a different name like
Call of Duty's fenik 45 SMG or the
lachmann series of rifles inherent a
reference to the caliber of the Chris
vector and the Heckler and [__] firearms
that inspired them
this is because player association with
popular weapons and in turn common
calibers has become so strong sometimes
a weapons aesthetic and a number will be
enough to tap into player recognition
for an iconic pop culture caliber this
unique cyberpunk 2077 sniper rifle for
example is a large powerful loud Beast
of a weapon and with a name like the 05
it's not hard to see the connection to
the real .50 caliber and rifles
calibers can also contribute to A Game's
World building games set in Russia or
those that take place in historical
Soviet locales will feature weapons and
calibers more common to those regions
whereas the campaigns from a more
Western point of view will more commonly
have the players equipped with firearms
and ammunition from NATO countries and
include AK type weapons almost
exclusively in the hands of enemies
something else that we've covered in our
AK-47 episode
and locales Venture further into the
fictional esoterra core apocalyptic the
detail of calibers can still pop up one
of the most popular and plentiful
sidearms in Fallout is the 10 millimeter
pistol the lore seems to suggest that it
is the Fallout universes parallel to a
nine millimeter pistol from our reality
as the series has stated it was very
common and issued to law enforcement and
Military before the invention of energy
weapons
foreign
millimeter is by no means a fictional
caliber it's an interesting one in the
world of Fallout at a glance 10
millimeter being one more than nine
millimeter immediately gives a sense
that in this alternate universe things
are a little bigger badder and more
dangerous with this world's threats
requiring a bigger bullet in turn it's
also a way to help separate this weird
world from our reality making one of the
first weapons you get in each game feel
characteristically one small step
removed from what many players might be
familiar with
another example is the m118 7.62 by 51
millimeter armor piercing full metal
jackaround used by the UNSC of Halo in
reality the 7.62 by 51 millimeter round
is a common NATO caliber used in weapons
like scar H psg1 or M60 while in our
world it's a larger caliber suited for
battle rifles or machine guns fired from
a bipod in Halo with centuries of recoil
dampening development it can be spewed
out of the standard issue of assault
rifle at up to 900 rounds per minute
in hardcore titles various firearms and
calibers can also go some way into
broadening the pool of loot a player
could find across their Adventures where
a Survivor may have a pile of ammunition
but not necessarily the weapon to make
use out of it this is most often felt
when games are accurate to a weapons
caliber and plays into the game's world
where resources and weaponry is scarce
as well as allowing for another layer of
depth as players have to consider not
only the firearm they carry but the
specific rounds as well
escape from tarkov is a great example of
this not only does the Game feature
highly detailed weapons but the calibers
ammunitions also have the same attention
to the specifics while caliber is a
factor and you're more likely to punch
through PMC armor with a rifle rather
than a pistol in Target the type of
round is often more important than the
dimensions of it with different options
within the same caliber having their own
damage profiles we call an armor
penetration values even to the point
that the slight differences between
civilian 223 and Military 5.56 by 45
millimeter rounds are factored in while
still being fired from the same weapon
and multiple calibers can even fit in
the same magazine but will potentially
fail to feed through the rifle
foreign
there are also the extremes of the
virtual caliber Spectrum where both the
biggest and smallest can be exaggerated
or overestimated weapons like Red Dead
Redemption 2's vomit rifle chambered in
0.22 makes it the weakest rifle in the
game it's recommended to be used against
small animals as to not damage their
pelts and without a headshot we'll
struggle against gunslinging foes yet in
reality its potential for lethality is
much more than Red Dead might suggest
much lower damage is a common Way games
balance weapons using the 0.22 cartridge
type but even smaller than that is the
2.7 millimeter bullet of the tiny
calibri pistol which appears in
Battlefield 1 more as a joke than
anything else with its hilariously
pitiful damage and range
here on the flip side larger calibers
like 50 cal are often used as a
storytelling device to imply a character
of power or skill in a character or even
simply shown to be much more common than
they are in reality something we touched
upon for the desert eagle in a previous
episode of loadout
when I first started to think about
calibers in video games my mind was
focused on the damage numbers and stats
but the more I rocked it back and forth
in my head the more interested I became
in the games that used calibers as a
narrative World building or gameplay
device just as much as an element of
Gunplay in recent years most of all fans
of Shooters have started to appreciate
the finer details of their games from
recreating virtual Firearms they're
familiar with implementing accurate
reloads weapon manipulation or inspect
animations to how the weapons perform
and are represented across a variety of
different games be the focused on Arcade
action or punishing realism whatever
your weapon of choice or however big the
bang maybe next time you're behind your
favorite weapon you'll notice the
Intriguing details of not just your
virtual firearm but also the digital
brass and steel flying from it
foreign
thank you so much for watching this
episode of Loadout on one of the smaller
and potentially more overlooked details
of our Shooters be sure to tell us what
else you'd like to see Loadout cover and
if you want more video game Firearms
content you can watch the previous
episodes of the show or check out our
weekly series of firearms expert reacts
where I show our friends at the Royal
armories a selection of guns from our
favorite games until next time I've been
your host Dave Jewett and I will see you
in the next one
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]